how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got the finale the final
episode of Marvel studios's secret
Invasion right away go ahead and let us
know what you thought of the finale in
the comments down below and the series
as a whole did you like it did you not
like it go ahead and rate it from 1 to
10 10 being the highest in the comments
down below now we assume that if you are
here you have seen the finale episode
but in case you are trying to avoid
spoilers for the final episode this is
your spoiler warning as we are going to
go deep into the spoilers or the finale
and the series so let's get started and
reminder if you're new be sure to
subscribe to the channel and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X a
PS5 some Marvel Legends items and some
DC items the winner gets to pick one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month now there is sort of a
Simplicity that comes with this finale
the finale really comes down to a few
scenes we have what is going on with
Fury Sonia fallsworth and the president
and of course fake roading and we have
what is going on with Gaia and gravic
but we open with what is seemingly a new
Nick Fury at the end of last episode we
saw the theory that we've seen in secret
Invasion who has been kind of run down
kind of like a retired Fury go back to
the old Nick Fury he put the eye patch
on he put his coat on and it looks like
we figured out who he called he called
Amelia Clarke's character Gaia he called
her and gave her the vial that he got
from the tombstone so no he didn't call
Captain Marvel he didn't call Abigail
brand and unfortunately and I know this
is going to hurt a lot of people he
didn't call Chloe Bennett's character
Daisy Johnson AKA Quake from Agents of
Shield nope he called Gaia and this Nick
Fury that we see in the beginning of
this episode that is made to seem like
the old Nick Fury is back is actually
Gaia however the old Nick Fury really is
back however he is not the one that is
going to greet gravic and he's very wise
to do so more on that in just a bit
first thing we need to talk about is
Nick Fury calling his wife Priscilla in
the beginning to essentially say bye and
take care of yourself good luck but if
you notice this detail it might actually
give away that this wasn't Nick Fury
calling but could have perhaps been Gaia
this Nick theory is calling Priscilla in
an Alleyway and if you look at the
background we can see a car that he
walks to at the end of the call and this
is the same car that we see in the very
next scene that Gaia uses one to get to
the location of gravic the scroll
sanctuary and two the one she uses to
distract the guards so this could have
been Gaia who called Priscilla maybe at
the direction of Nick Fury maybe she did
it on her own or it could have been Nick
Fury and he simply met up with Gaia and
then gave her the car it honestly could
be either one of them but regardless
Fury does go back to Priscilla in the
end ask for one last chance and
eventually does go off to saber with her
but that's just a small detail to notice
so Gaia uses the car as a distraction
kills both the guards who are scroll and
she shoots one even after he's dead
showing that she really is mad at the
fact that these people specifically
graphic but some of these scroll were
supporting gravic and gravity killed
parents meanwhile Roadie is with the
president and there's a female Admiral
there who states that they don't know
that this attack was from the Russians
it could have been a false attack and
the president of Russia who they call
vladimoff No Doubt a play on Vladimir
Putin the actual president of Russia
right now says that he strenuously
denies the attack then Roadie takes some
shots at the Russian president and this
has kind of taken some shots at the real
Russian president as well but we know
that this is the scroll Bravo and she is
working for graphic and she is trying to
get the United States to launch an
attack on Russia essentially starting
World War III so Vara is trying to make
that happen and she's even went as far
as making the president's own remarks
for him and they don't show this on
screen but ultimately rava does convince
him to make the call he is going to
launch a bomb attack on Russia later on
Nick Fury and fallsworth try to convince
him to call off the strike in which of
course he does when he realizes that
Roadie is indeed a scroll and in all
honesty that pretty much wraps up that
scene it was pretty straightforward we
saw Sonya fallsworth be absolutely
incred incredible taking out all of the
Secret Service Nick Fury came in and did
the same they had Roadie or rava hostage
and once rabba made a move they shot
rava in the head and of course she
returned to her scroll form after she
was dead showing the president that
Roadie was a scroll and the attacks were
false they were being made by a scroll
trying to start World War III this
doesn't come without its repercussions
though we'll talk about that in just a
bit meanwhile while all of this is
happening Gaia of course disguises Nick
Fury makes her way to gravic and she
puts on a show last episode graphic told
Nick Fury to bring him the Harvest the
DNA of almost all of the superheroes
that were there during the battle for
Earth and we find out that there was a
lot of DNA that they collected but more
on that in just a bit graphic also told
Fury to bring some iodide pills because
of the radiation skrull aren't affected
by radiation so they can live in these
radioactive plants but Fury as a human
would be greatly affected by the
radiation so when Gaia goes in she
starts to put on a show she starts
coughing she starts taking the iodide
pills and and really makes it seem like
she is Nick Fury side note all of the
humans that were being kept below new
scrollos in the same plant seem to not
really be that affected by radiation or
the fact that they were there for a
pretty long time but Gaia gets to
graphic disguises Fury she comes in
coughing and she really sells it but
then she says a lot of things that are
true for Nick Fury and keep in mind that
when skrull take the bodies of people
when they take the forms of people they
can get recent memories recent thoughts
and this is why Gaia really knows what
Nick Fury felt what she is saying is
kind of coming from Nick Fury because
she has his thoughts and here we see the
pain of graphic he was a young kid and
Nick Fury was his hero so he did
everything he could to impress him
including killing humans who had
families who had wives husbands kids and
he essentially said that tore him apart
but he did it all for Nick Fury because
he promised to find him a home and of
course he never did and that's why
gravic had taken it into his own hands
to kind of make a new scrollless for the
scroll however he's really just become
about revenge at this point and graphic
just basically sees a dying Nick Fury
and he says come on what's the backup
plan are you gonna call the Avengers in
is there somebody here in the room using
an invisibility cloak and which kind of
there really was Gaia was disguised as
Nick Fury little stealth Action there
but not before graphic expresses
everything to who he thinks is Fury and
I just have to applaud Kingsley Ben
adir's acting in this scene and of
course the little Joker line that we got
here the look at me
walk me
now in this scene we find out really why
Nick Fury never kept his promise and
this is kind of coming from fury it's
Fury's memories that Gaia is using to
express how Fury would feel but it's
also kind of Gaia expressing a little
bit of her own attitude as well stating
yes I failed you as fury because she
believes that Fury failed her as well
that's why she switched sides and was
following graphic originally in the
beginning he was gonna make a new home
for them Fury never did that and we find
out that Nick Fury knew within a few
years of searching that there was no
other planet out there for the skrulls
so Fury knew that the only way to get
them a new home was to build them one on
earth and in this scene you can even see
the expression on gravic's Face the I
wish you would have done that expression
and then he even asked why didn't you do
it telling us that that would have
actually been acceptable to him it would
have been acceptable to the Scrolls if
they could have simply had a home on
Earth that's all they want but Fury
explains that it was easier to save the
lives of 8 billion people than it is to
change their hearts and their minds and
gravac asks even for Nick Fury and he
asked this as somebody who used to and
probably still kind of does admire Nick
Fury and who he is and what he's done
for everyone and at this point we even
see graphic take a step back he sits
down and he wants to hear what Fury is
going to say he wants to know why his
hero the person that he trusted did not
deliver on his promise to his people he
wants to know why Fury did not give the
skrulls a home so he sits down and then
Fury starts talking about the blip and
he says that as he was essentially
dusting away he felt relief because he
no longer had to fight he thought that
was it it was done it was dead and never
coming back but of course he did
ultimately come back and then he went on
saber and he kind of just stayed there
but he explains that it came back
because of graphic he was called and was
told what graphic was doing and he felt
responsible for gravic because he was
the youngest scroll on Nick Fury's team
and he felt like he should have taught
him more and from here on out it's kind
of just a play by Gaia to essentially
become more of a super scroll herself so
her slash Fury says take it take the
Harvest take all the DNA and leave and
take the scroll with you she says that
knowing it wasn't going to happen kravik
has essentially already turned on the
remaining scroll anyway she just wants
him to use it so she can get the powers
as well and that essentially works the
Harvest is real gravic does confirm this
and he activates the machine with Nick
Fury Gaia inside of it now let me know
if you thought at first Nick Fury was
about to get the powers of all of these
Avengers or if you actually thought that
it was Gaia all along but ultimately
gravity gets the powers of what we've
counted to be 23 different DNA samples
giving them 23 different types of powers
rabbit gives that to himself but also
gives it to Gaia who of course finally
reveals herself once she she punches him
with the arm of a Hulk so this fight we
have broken down frame by frame and
we're going to show you and tell you
what power each of them are using each
time when graphic loads up the Harvest
we can actually see a screen that shows
us all of the DNA samples minus a few
that were shown in episode 2 like the
extremists but every other one is listed
and a good amount of them are used in
the fight scene that we see here keep in
mind some can't be seen even though they
may be being used at the time for
example the Winter Soldier their super
soldier serum in that ability Thor
Odin's son's DNA is in there as well so
the strength of a God is being used like
I said we counted 23 different DNA
samples and here are the 23 that can be
seen ghost Captain America corvus glaive
Thanos and outrider Proxima midnight
Frost Beast ebony ma Korg Drax coal
obsidian mantis Captain Marvel Gamora
Abomination Hulk black panther chittari
Val Valkyrie Thor odinson Flora Colossus
which is Groot the Winter Soldier and
the extremist all of which except for
the extremists were present during the
big battle of Avengers endgame even
Thanos and the children of Thanos call
obsidian ebony ma Proxima midnight and
Corpus glaive were there from the other
timeline as far as we know the only ones
that weren't there during the Battle of
Avengers endgame was Ghost the frost
Beast Abomination and the extremists all
the other samples they would have
collected after that battle so now let's
break this battle scene down frame by
frame like I mentioned we start off with
gravic as a super scroll attacking who
he believes is Nick Fury Nick Fury of
course blocks the attack and then turns
his arm into the Hulk's arm and punches
him through the roof of the building of
course it is then revealed that this is
in fact Gaia graphic lands on a car and
then we can see that part of his arm is
Groot or what's listed as Flora Colossus
as we continue the fight Gaia makes her
right arm into the extremists telling
gravic that he killed her father and her
mother basically stating now you're
about to die graphic turns his other arm
into the arm of abomination specifically
in the style of the new Abomination that
we saw in shangchi and She-Hulk if you
take a look at his ear you can tell it's
like the new style of abomination Gaia
tells gravic that he's flailing he's
weak and as she says he's weak she turns
her arm into the arm of Drax from the
Guardians of the Galaxy Gaia charges at
grabbeck as he throws a car at her but
she phases through the car because she's
using the powers of ghost from Ant-Man
and the WASP graphic then turns his arm
that's Abomination into the arm of Korg
in reply to that Gaia changes one of her
arms into a sword made out of ice most
likely getting this from the frost Giant
and then her other arm she turns into
korgs as well and it looks like Gaia is
winning momentarily she manages to stab
grabbeck through the chest with the ice
sword but then gravic turns his arm that
was groot's arm into the arm of ebony Ma
many of you will remember ebony ma from
Avengers Infinity War where he fought
against Doctor Strange Iron Man and kind
of Bruce Banner and Spider-Man he had
the power of telekinesis and Graphics
seems to have caught on to that pretty
quickly using it to smash a boulder
right into Gaia then he throws her up
into a pole and as she falls he kicks
her with the leg of the Hulk now Gaia
gets up and turns her arm into the arm
of Cole obsidian who was also there in
that fight against Iron Man doctor
strange wristbander and Spider-Man she
charges at gravic and graphic also has
one arm like Cole obsidians and the
other side is Thanos and right before
the two get to each other they both use
the powers of Captain Marvel taking off
into the air now in the air as they're
fighting it looks like gravic has got a
hold of Gaia and is not letting go until
she has a stroke of Genius and turns
into mantis and uses mantis powers to
make him go to sleep graphic falls to
the ground as Gaia remains in the sky as
Captain Marvel however graphic then
starts to use the powers of Captain
Marvel as well while shooting energy
beams at Gaia she hits the ground as
Captain Marvel and we see gravic Hill
due to the extremists and Gaia then
turns one of her arms into the arm of
abomination on the right side and on the
left coal obsidians she charges at
graphic and Graphics shoots some more
Captain Marvel energy at her but she
phases through it using the powers of
ghost she grabs a hold of graphic and he
says you're just like your father just
like them and Gaia releases her rage and
puts a huge energy blast through the
middle of graphic finishing the fight
once and for all although I would say
that the extremists probably could heal
him maybe he could come back but I'm
thinking Graphics done for now but if
you think otherwise let us know your
thoughts Down Below in the comments now
after the fight she goes and releases
the people who were being held captive
in the pods the people that the scroll
had taken their identities over and of
course who do we find down there the
actual Roadie and Everett Ross along
with many other people that we have
actually seen throughout the series who
we knew to be scroll many of them
powerful world leaders and they don't
tell us exactly how long they've been
down there for but Gaia simply says a
long time now notice everybody is pretty
much fine except for Roadie because he
does not have the devices on his legs to
help him walk so he needs help
now after all this happened three major
things take place one is what I believe
to be a huge future X-Men setup we see
President Ritz and say that the
terrorist attack on him was performed by
the Scrolls a shape-shifting enemy race
and in his address he states that he's
proposing a bill to Congress that
designates all
off-world-born species enemy combatants
and he ends his address by stating that
we will find you and we will kill every
last one of you keep in mind this bill
would also affect people like Thor who
was born off-world including the rest of
the asgardians who are still on Earth
right now in New Asgard plus not to
mention the Guardians of the Galaxy
except for Star-Lord since he was born
on Earth but this does label a lot of
our heroes to be villains according to
this bill but it also really sets up
mutants to be discriminated against as
well which is a big premise in the the
comics the war between the humans and
the mutants Professor Xavier fighting to
exist alongside the humans while Magneto
seeks to rule over them this sets up the
X-Men in a very very big way it sets it
up for at least the United States and
probably the rest of the world to see
mutants as a threat so a big X-Men
mutants set up there the other big
ending scene is Gaia is seemingly now
working with MI6 what's crazy is Gaia is
essentially now one of the strongest
beings in the entire universe she has 23
different superpowers inside of her body
she can be the Hulk Captain Marvel she
can heal with the extremist she can be
Thanos she has telekinesis because of
ebony ma she has so many different
powers in her it's going to be hard for
anybody to defeat her and now she's
working within my sex and who knows what
Sonia falseworth has up her sleeve so
obviously this is something that is
definitely going to come into play in
the future in a really big way and of
course the last and final scene is Nick
Fury making up with his wife telling her
he loves her as she is she says that she
loves him and for the time being she
goes up with him to save her and the two
of them get to be together for at least
a pretty long time husband and wife and
she gets to be in her true form her
scroll form so happy endings mostly all
around if you don't count graphic and
Talos and Maria Hill and a lot of the
other scroll who followed graphic but
mostly Happy Endings kind of but that is
it for secret Invasion please let us
know what you thought about the finale
and the series as a whole in the
comments down below you can also find us
on patreon you can check out our website
and our Discord server and you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof